check from the queen forces the black
king back into the firing line and this
is a discovered check and ending the
game magnus last ditch attempt instead
of trying to run in this direction he
moves his queen up the board but
you can do anything here you can even
just get greedy grab a couple of pawns
discover check yes the king gets to the
corner another check but you've won so
many pawns in the process
um maybe there's something even better
okay he allows the black king to run i
thought this is nice moving the rook can
come in as well so it's just
i mean well played dingo he's been
fantastic and he is a deserved winner um
all he needs to do now is keep the white
queen safe um you can even just capture
the black queen but if you keep the
white queen safe
yeah winner is the right word simon okay
he does it even better job brings his
queen to the seventh round conquering
the seventh rank and i've noticed when
he's confident he always has a sip of
this massive bottle of water you know so
we have a result
it's over
dingley ran you guys beats world
champion magnus crossing world number
one